-Guys, it is Tuesday.
It is time for "WeTweet."
Here we go.
-♪ WeTweet ♪
♪ WeTweet ♪
-Alright, so this is "WeTweet."
This is where we, as a group,
decide something that we
should post on Twitter, okay?
Now, I'm going to show you
five different tweets,
and we're all gonna vote
on whether you like each one
or not, okay?
You all have voting clickers
at your seats.
You can vote for all of them
if you like.
You can vote for none of them
Whatever you want, and we're
going to see the results live.
Higgins, Roots,
you also have clickers.
-Yes.
-Have you ever been correct
on these?
-No, I haven't.
-No?
Higgins, have you?
-No.
-No? Okay, maybe tonight
will be successful.
-Tonight, this is my night.
-You can vote yes or no,
yea or nay.
Whatever tweet
gets the most likes,
we will tweet it out
live on the show
so you can all like it
and "WeTweet" it.
[ Laughter ]
It's a shared experience.
You guys ready for this?
The first --
The first tweet is...
-[ Laughs ]
-Wow.
I can already kind of tell.
-I like it.
-I like it, too.
I just feel like it's --
The silence is a thumbs-down.
-It's humor.
-Okay.
I think the -- the votes are in.
And now let's see
the results here.
Yeah, no.
They did not like that.
-Wow.
-Resounding no.
No, thanks.
No air horn.
[ Imitates air horn ]
This next one is...
[ Laughter ]
-Come on, that's good, too.
-Make your vote.
Yeah, here we go.
Now let's see the results
on this one here.
What do you think of that one?
-Whoa!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I think they went a little
too heavy on that one.
-Yeah, that's 160.
I voted yes.
-Yeah, here we go.
Alright.
This next one is...
[ Light laughter ]
[ Jazz music plays ]
Not for you?
-Not for me.
I don't care for that.
I don't care for
that type of humor.
-Let's see the results
on that one there.
Let's see what we got.
Yeah, no. I agree.
I agree with this one.
This next one, though, I --
-You like this next one?
-Well, again, I don't want
to pick favorites,
but you can vote for all of them
or none of them.
That's the rule.
Or you can put
your clickers down.
You can go, "I don't
feel like doing this."
Yeah, "I came here
to be entertained.
I don't want to entertain you."
-"I don't want to work.
Why don't you decide
what tweet it is?"
-Here we go.
Here's the tweet here.
Next up is...
[ Laughter ]
-Is "Twinkie" a euphemism
for something?
-No, no, it is not.
No, it is not.
-Okay. I'm sorry.
-No, it is not.
It's a --
-Twinkie.
-It's a Hostess --
-It's kind of tan-colored tube.
-Yes.
-Filled with cream.
Got it.
-Alright.
-This is a family show.
I'm voting no.
Disgusting.
-Let's see the results
on that one right there.
-Whoa!
-Oh, boy!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Wow!
-I think it's a good idea.
I think it's a good gag.
Someone yawns,
you shove a Twinkie.
-Sure. A Hostess.
Hostess comes over.
-The last one here is...
[ Laughter ]
-Shhhh!
-That's pretty good.
Yeah, I like that one, too.
Okay, everyone.
Let's see the results right now.
Right there.
Yeah. Not bad.
Alright, I think we know.
Looks like the winner is...
Yes!
I'm going to post this
during the commercial break.
Thank you for helping me out.
If you see it on your feed,
give it a like,
give it a "WeTweet," and enjoy.